Hey guys, Amy here on DNews answering your
questions about muscles!
Neko recently asked us if we can make a video
about why our muscles grow big when we exercise.
We all want to get big and strong, building
muscles to have lean bodies and to be able
to squat our coworkers for funsies.
But what actually happens when you workout
that makes your muscles grow?
There’s more to muscles than you might think.
We have different types of muscles: cardiac,
smooth, and skeletal muscles.
Smooth muscles are responsible for the contracting
movements of hollow organs like blood vessels,
the gastrointestinal tract, bladder, and uterus.
Skeletal muscles are made up of bundles of
individual muscle fibers that are themselves
strands of proteins that grab onto one another
and pull.
These muscle are attached to bones, and it’s
the contraction, that pulling, that causes
your bones to move around your joints.
That’s what happens when your muscles contract.
These are controlled by the somatic nervous
system.
The cardiac muscle, the one that makes your
heart pump blood throughout your body, is
involuntarily controlled.
Your heart and the muscles that control it
are obviously an important part of working
out or playing sports, but when we’re talking
about building muscles we need to focus on
skeletal muscles.
There’s a little more to skeletal muscles
than just the fibers that make them up.
Muscle are broadly categorized into two types.
Type I or slow twitch muscles are more efficient
at using oxygen to generate energy.
And as the name suggests they can work longer
before being exhausted so these are the ones
that you use for duration sports like long
distance running.
Type II or fast twitch muscles rely on anaerobic
metabolism to create fuel, or more simply,
they use your body’s stored energy for shorts
bursts of activity.
These are the ones your body uses when sprinting
or weightlifting.
When you build muscle, you’re actually breaking
down these muscle fibres and building them
back up.
There are a couple of ways to do this.
Hypertrophy is an increase in the size of
the muscle due to an increase in the size
of the muscle fibers; while hyperplasia happens
when you actually split muscle fibers to eventually
grow more of them, though some trainers suspect
that this splitting doesn’t actually create
new fibers, it just changes existing ones.
The exact process of muscle growth isn’t
entirely understood, but leading theories
say that lifting something heavy, like a weight,
breaks the muscle fibers apart, and then those
fibers grow back in a way that allows them
to compensate for the damage and protect themselves
against future damage.
This happens naturally, but lifting speeds
the cycle up so you rebuild muscle faster,
and the more you breakdown the more you grow
back!
Which is why you need to rest between workouts;
you need to give your body time to repair
itself, and help that process along with protein.
And that’s where the increase to muscles
comes from.
Speaking of bulking up,Toyota has been doing
some augmentation of their own with the TRD
line of Toyota Trucks.
Enhanced to rule the off-road!
So does this clear things up or do you still
have more questions about muscles?
Let us know in the comments below or on Twitter
@DNews.
And of course, for more DNews every single
day of the week, don’t forget to subscribe!